gerade wenn du mit kindern gärtner es
ist natürlich toll gemüse anzubauen wo
zwischen aussaat und ernte gar nicht so
viel zeit vergeht deswegen stelle ich
euch heute fünf gemüse vor
die ruckzuck erntereif sind ich muss
zugeben dass ich als erwachsene auch oft
viel zu ungeduldig bin im garten und
deswegen immer wieder froh bin wenn ich
schnell wachsende gemüse anbauen so dass
dann auch schnell eine erste ernte
ansteht also bühne frei für die fünf
raketen der gemüse
sagt nicht ich hätte euch nicht gewarnt
da sehen wir noch mal einer behaupten
dass gärten langweilig wäre also ihr
seht hier geht's hoch her im garten wenn
ihr noch mehr spannende gartentipps
weiter abonniert den kanal und drückt
die glocke radieschen sind mit die
flottesten kandidaten im gemüsegarten es
gibt sorten die schon nach einem monat
erntereif sind die sind absolut
unkompliziert an zu bauen also auch toll
für kinder wenn du radieschen aus selbst
dann gibst du einfach alle 3 cm ein
samenkorn in die erde bedeckt das
ungefähr zwei zentimeter dick mit erde
hält das ein paar tage lang feucht und
nach drei bis fünf tagen kannst du schon
die ersten pflanzen wie ihm das auch
noch gut zu wissen es ist dass man
radieschen rechtzeitig ernten sollte
also sobald die ihre radieschen größe
erreicht haben solltest du die ernten
und essen weil die ziemlich schnell
verholzen wenn man die im beet vergisst
was vielleicht einige von euch
überrascht ist dass auch einige möhren
sorten super schnell eine erste ernte
abwerfen meine absolute lieblingsstadt
für wenn es mal schnell gehen muss ist
die sorte gonzenheimer tribe höhere
eignet sich auch sehr gut dazu
und bevor das sommergemüse in die beete
wandert noch mal eine kleine höheren
ernte einzufahren da erntet man dann so
fingerdicke bunten während die super
super lecker sind
ich habe einen mini videokurs für euch
erstellt als kleinen kick start in die
neue gartensaison wo ich euch zeige wie
man einen pflegeleichten üppigen und
super ertragreichen gemüse garten anlegt
und sein eigenes gemüse anbaut da könnt
ihr euch gerne kostenlos für anmelden
entsteht auch immer eine ganz tolle
gemeinschaft das ist einfach von mir für
euch um euch noch einen besseren start
ins neue gartenjahr zu ermöglichen ihr
könnt euch gerne hier oben anmelden da
pläne ich mal den link ein ansonsten ist
der link auch unten in der video
beschreibung ich freue mich auf alle die
dabei sind dass es immer eine super
nette gemeinschaft die da entsteht also
meldet euch gerne an
der link ist unten in der video
beschreibung salate kommen ja in den
unterschiedlichsten farben und formen
daher und werfen auch super schnell eine
erste ernte ab vor allem wenn man sie
als pflücksalat anbaut bei der aussaat
muss man bedenken dass salat ein licht
kaymer ist das heißt man darf die samen
nicht mit der erde bedecken sondern die
müssen nur obenauf liegen dann einfach
gut ein gießen und die nächsten tage gut
feucht halten bis die ersten pflanzen
auf gehen man kann alle salat sollten
auch als pflücksalat anbauen dann erntet
man sehr viel schneller als wenn man
wartet bis sich große köpfe gebiet
dafür selbst zu den salat einfach
dichter aus als wenn du köpfe ernten
möchtest und schneidet dann wenn der
salat ungefähr zehn bis 15 zentimeter
hoch ist die blätter ungefähr drei bis
vier zentimeter über dem boden ab so
kannst du die immer wieder begehrten
weil die salate natürlich immer wieder
neu austreiben und neue blätter bilden
und hass so eine viel schnellere ernte
und kannst jede pflanze bis zu fünf mal
beenden wir bauen im winter immer die
sorte baku an eine ganz tolle winter
salat sollte eigentlich für kopfsalat
die wir aber glück salat anbauen und so
den ganzen winter über unseren eigenen
salat ernten können im freiland also
eine supertolle sorte kann ich nur jedem
empfehlen wenn ihr wissen wollt welche
gemüse wie im winter sonst noch so an
bauen dann verlinke ich euch gerne mal
meine winterliche gartentour hier oben
da zeige ich euch wie unser garten im
winter aussieht und was wir da immer
noch anbauen
[Musik]
welche gemüse wachsen denn bei euch
besonders schnell und besonders gut
schreibt mir das mal unten in die
kommentare ich finde es immer so schön
damit euch zu plaudern ein weiteres
raketen gemüse sind buschbohnen die wir
für trockene erste ernte ab es ist nur
wichtig zu beachten dass man die erst
aussehen kann wenn es draußen frostfrei
ist ich benutze busspuren super gerne
als lückenfüller vor allem in der
zweiten saisonhälfte wenn die beete im
sommer nach und nach abgeerntet werden
um auf demselben beet vor dem winter
noch mal ein zweiter ernte einfahren zu
können wichtig bei buschbohnen ist dass
man sie regelmäßig geerntet weil die
pflanzen dann aber mehr produzieren und
b die boden richtig schön zart und
knackig sind nicht so verholzt das geht
nämlich super schnell wenn man sich zu
lange zeit mit der ernte lässt dass die
bohnen dann verholzen mein freund will
jetzt gleich mittagessen machen ich habe
meinen ernte kopf abgeliefert das heißt
wir gehen wieder ausgetrieben da weiter
und räume die küche für ihn keine brings
super gut kochen habe ich das schon mal
erwähnt ja ich weiss ich sehe anders aus
es ist nämlich ein neuer tag der clip
den ich eigentlich jetzt hier einblenden
wollte war leider komplett verschwommen
so dass ich das jetzt noch mal neu
aufnehmen dabei hatte ich eigentlich die
perfekte überleitung schaut euch nämlich
fragen was ist grün und schaut durchs
schlüsselloch spinat der spinat ist das
fünfte raketen gemüse der wächst nämlich
auch super super schnell und falls
irgendwer von euch jetzt denkt a-final
durchweg doch nicht dann würde ich euch
herzlich einladen mal spinat aus dem
eigenen garten zu probieren das ist
nämlich gar kein vergleich dazu wie
diese aktiv kümmert aus dem supermarkt
schmeckt spinat lasagne aus frischem
spinat mit schafskäse und sahne göttlich
frage ich euch wenn ihr spielen wollt
dann könnt ihr ungefähr eine 3 bis 5 cm
und samenkorn ablegen und gut andrücken
mit ungefähr zwei zentimeter erde
bedecken und angießen wenn ihr den
spielern etwas enger seid dann könnt ihr
baby spieleragenten der ist dann auch
noch schneller
erntereife als der kurse und mac noch
zarter und feiner das würde ich euch auf
jeden fall empfehlen wenn ihr auf eine
schnelle ihren haushalt generell ist ein
super tolles gemüse und ich würde
wirklich alle spielarten profil unter
euch dazu zählen das mal auszuprobieren
wenn du dich noch nicht für das bootcamp
angemeldet hast dann macht das jetzt die
anmeldung ist wie gesagt hier unten in
der video beschreibung ansonsten kannst
du dir hier drüben eine playlist zum
thema pflanzplan erstellen anschauen
falls du noch keinen pflanzplan habe
nehme ich dich da an die hand und zeigt
ihr schritt für schritt wie das geht
dankeschön fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten videos